Hi
you know who we are but let's meet
another hero
this is lance corporal dan miller dan
and the other brave marines of second
battalion are helping keep you safe
from the super villain threat we're
proud to fly alongside them
and now we could use your support that's
right maeve with our new campaign
saving america here i go you guys wish
me luck
oh fyi not a real base
as if homelander and maeve are going to
eat mre's and
piss in a ditch with the rest of the
crew yeah we're filming right now excuse
me also
you might recognize army boy as hotel
clerk number two from the devil's breath
episode of criminal minds beyond borders
well
hello oh my god hi my nana's your
biggest fan
i'm stormfront great right yeah from
seattle
right portland actually your highness
holy your eyes are really
blue up close
you are fun it's been a hoot
but we got work to do so let's get back to it
oh totally uh they just wanted me to
meet you
who oh the boy's on 82.
i'm the new girl wait what are you
talking about
oh hi i'm in the seven
replacing translucent god bless his soul
ink's barely dry but uh yeah reporting
for duty
yeah um no i don't think that this
is not true i don't know anything about this
wow well uh
stormfront who
delivered the good news oh uh
mr edgar the big guy
all right wonderful
great all right
great!
Well
I think this is going great
I'm on page 134. Chain of command
doesn't apply to other military
contractors in the field i don't see why
it should apply to us
caprese sandwich when they're in actual
combat whom exactly do your heroes
report to
same person as always me
spicy chicken cilantro wraps subheading 16.
We need a top secret yankee white
designation for compound V. Come on Stan
only one man okays that you want to
stroll into the oval office and start
barking orders oh yes
half our own heroes don't know they have
compound V in their veins
you want china finding out this one
best efforts to limit collateral damage
we'd prefer stronger wording well it's
standard language for our new york
contract
la chicago exactly what casualty
allowance are we looking at here
officially zero of course but cone of
silence
34 percent.
Veggie frittata?
just call me
you guys ready?
rousing music...Hans Zimmer!
Title card,
cut to black.
That is amazing!
Welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my new boys season 2
trailer video and breakdown of that big
live stream where they previewed what's
going on during season 2 they introduced
the stormfront character in a much
bigger way
there's a bunch of easter eggs from the
boys comics so we'll break it all down
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos
because of what they're doing during
season 2 with the way that they release
the episodes i'll actually be able to do
videos for every single episode so i'm
actually really happy about this
the official season 2 release date is
also september 4th which is labor day
weekend so it's a little bit later than
they premiered season one
but because of the virus everything has
been delayed by a couple weeks so that's
why it's premiering a little bit later
than season one did
they're eight episodes total and
basically starting with the footage in
this clip here
this is sort of a funny tongue-in-cheek
clip of them filming an advertisement
for the boys
in the military they also screen the
first three minutes of episode one i'll
talk about that in a second too but i'll
talk about the stormfront footage first
so this is them filming an advertisement
that you'll see show up on people's tvs
within the context of the show
it's queen wave and homelander because
they're the two most powerful members at
this time even though stormfront is
crazy powerful and a slightly different
way that they explain
she shows up filming everything selfie
style just annoying the hell out of them
they don't know what's going on but she
says that she's there to replace
translucent who was killed off by huey
early during season one
she tells them that mr edgar told her
that she was joining the team
mr edgar is giancarlo esposito's
character from season one he was
stillwell's boss
inside vaude american during season one
it sounds like he's much bigger during
season 2
based on that opening three-minute scene
with him negotiating with the military
during this livestream too all the
actors were taking shots of blue liquid
to make it look like they were taking
shots of compound v
so they obviously made a bunch of
changes with the stormfront character
from the comics
i'll talk about that in a second because
they revealed one of her powers that
isn't a comic book power
is actually reading people's minds this
is that they kind of redesigned the
character for the age of social media so
the way that she's filming it in this
scene is kind of baked into the nature
of the character they'll kind of explain
that
but just like the comic book version of
her character she
is worse than homelanders so to speak if
you don't know aya cash she's actually
from a show called you're the worst
she's in a bunch of other stuff she's
actually pretty fantastic comedic
actress
so the way that they're explaining her
on the show here is that they are doing
some of the nazi stuff
in her backstory but unless they're
purposefully trying to mislead us i
don't think that she's
actually from world war ii the way the
comic book storm front was
stormfront in the comics was sort of the
beta version for homelander
they used all this vocal bomb research
during world war ii that he used to
create
stormfront then later when he came to
the united states through operation
paperclip
they used to create homelander and make
him that much more powerful
so in the comics homelander is more
powerful than stormfront but the thing
that they've done to sort of balance the
scales on the tv show and make her
more of a sort of thorn in homelanders
side at least at the beginning
is give her the ability to read people's
minds so the reason they do something
like that is just so that he can't hide
anything from her she'll know
everything that he's done but like they
said she's just
as bad if not worse than homelander and
they also said that she would slowly
earn homelanders trust
during the season i think that that just
means that they'll slowly reveal
why she's even worse than homelander
during the season but they did say when
they first meet
he absolutely cannot stand her they
absolutely just hate each other's guts
the difference with stormfront's powers
in the comics is that he can fly
and he can spit lightning he's sort of a
combination of captain marvel or shazam
from dc
as well as thor from marvel comics he's
from a team called payback which is an
easter egg for the avengers in the
marvel universe even though the seven is
sort of an easter egg for the justice
league in the dc universe
because it's the boys they combine a lot
of dc and marvel easter eggs
in season 2 so we'll see how many new
characters they introduce
the opening three minutes there is
giancarlo esposito's character signing
the contracts to put supers in the
military
season 2 will deal with a lot of the
consequences of what they did during
season one
that was all about homelander
manipulating the media to make people
think that they absolutely needed
supers in the military because they're
all these terrorist cells
that they were running compound v2 to
create foreign superheroes
so in episode one in this opening scene
they're basically just following through
on that
and you have a jim beaver's character
who's also from supernatural eric kripke
who's the showrunner on the boys also
did the supernatural tv show a long time
ago so there's a lot of supernatural
stuff going on here it's kind of funny
they talk about the standard contracts
that they have with the other cities
they joke about collateral damage jim
beaver's like okay look we've got to be
really careful about this collateral
damage and giancarlo esposito is
basically saying
they'll be 34 collateral damage meaning
they will cause just as much damage as
they prevent it's just hilarious
34 that's just a crazy amount of
collateral damage
then you have that scene in syria with
black noir on a mission just going
around ripping everyone apart it's
another terrorist
cell where someone has gotten compound v
so obviously he's there to kill the new
super but then they sort of joke about
his powers a little bit too they give
you this big surprise like oh wait a
minute he got soaked with heat vision
but it didn't destroy him it was able to
burn him quite a bit so you see a little
bit under his mask that's a bit of a
teaser like will we see what's going on
underneath the mask
this is the actor who plays black noir
underneath that mask
so they might be changing the comics
just a little bit i know everyone who's
read the comics knows his secret
identity so please don't post those
spoilers in the comments because there
is a big secret twist with black noir's
character
but i think they just want to show you
that he has some hidden secret abilities
like he's not just a martial artist he
doesn't just have super strength
then when he rips through all these
other people here and goes to the little
boy's room
that's also a reference to black noir in
the comics and all the terrible
terrible things that he does to children
so i don't think i need to over explain
that too much you kind of kind of got
that vibe there from him just trying to
mess with that little kid it's way way
worse in the comics so if you want to
get the full dose of it just read the
boy's comic book
but then instead of doing that you see
him turn leave and go out the window
so i think that's the tv show saying
that we're not going to do
that terrible terrible part of the black
noir comic book character
even though the tv show just gets really
really gory and really violent they're
not going to go
that crazy patton oswalt narrated that
live stream with them talking about all
their characters during season 2
but he did not reveal who he's playing
during season 2.
my big theory is that he's actually
going to play the legend from the comic
book
the legend is a character who's based on
stan lee he's an older character who
works with the boys as an
information broker he just knows
everything about superheroes and because
he's really old he's been around since
the beginning of the superhero era so he
knows everything about every single
superhero
it's meant to be a reference to stan lee
being sort of the godfather of comic
books knowing all these things about
these comic book characters going back
years and years and years
so we'll see he could be playing
somebody else but everybody let me know
what you think about all the footage and
what your big questions for season 2 are
what will probably happen too because
the season isn't premiering till
september 4th is that there'll be
another clip or some more promos before
that happens sometime during july and
august
but the way they're dropping the
episodes is a little bit different so i
said they're dropping them weekly but
it's
a little bit different for the first
couple of episodes so on september 4th
when the season premieres
they're dropping the first three
episodes binge style i will do videos
for all three of those episodes
but then what they're going to do with the
rest of the five episodes because
there's eight episodes total
is release them once per week so it just
makes it a little bit easier for me to
do videos for every single episode
that says that the reason they're doing
that is because the episodes are so
crazy
and so big that they just want to give
people more time to talk about each of
them so that it isn't just a big pump
and dump style where it's all come and
gone within a weekend
so that just means a lot more videos for
the boys season two episodes from me so
for those of you that really like season
one there'll just be a lot more boys
content on my channel this summer
and i know everybody has been dying for
new content from tv from movies because
of the virus everything has been delayed
so much
the marvel disney plus series will also
be dropping sometime later in the fall
too so i'll be talking about that stuff
in my marvel videos while you wait for
everything click here for that other
boys season 2 trailer and click here for
my brand new doctor strange 2 multiverse
of madness video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!